[Music]
does d-platforming violate a speaker's
first amendment rights
senator josh hawley has repeatedly
claimed that the cancellation of his
book deal
after he challenged the election results
was quote a direct assault on the first
amendment
and others suggest that twitter violated
president donald trump's free speech
rights by deleting his account
but this is a common misconception of
our rights
the first amendment says that congress
shall make no law abridging freedom of
speech
the 14th amendment extends that
prohibition to state and local
government
but with rare exceptions the
constitution does not place similar
restrictions on private actors
i can write a letter to the editor but
the new york times is not required to
print it
in fact forcing the times or any other
private company to publish statements
against its will
violates the publisher's own first
amendment right to decide what it wishes
to say on its platform
and the same is true of twitter the
first amendment does not protect speech
it merely prevents the government from
deciding who gets to speak
and who does not do you think twitter's
decision to block trump was just
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei